welcome back to Las Vegas now Father's
Day is almost here and it's a great
opportunity to test your dad's speak
skills and find out you know the gift
that proves you know him better than
anyone in your family whether you handed
you whether he handed you a list dropped
hints or you thought he dropped him okay
so you probably know at the very least
what department to shop in and we spoke
with lifestyle expert Kia Malone to
learn about the hottest trends for
active dads lifestyle expert Kia Malone
is a pro at finding the right gifts her
advice is to make sure you're paying
attention you know I really try to
listen for those clues or those hints
that my husband may drop and you know
say hey I could really use another pair
of golf clubs or you know I could really
use an another this and so then I
started building my list online
especially at a place where I know I can
find everything Malone says her go-to
store for Father's Day is Dick's
Sporting Goods I love shopping here at
Dick's Sporting Goods because you know
there's a wide variety of those products
including the yeti line for the family
fisherman in your life don't forget
about the mystery tackle box bass
fishing kit and for the golfer in your
life the latest and greatest from
Callaway golf including this Paradigm X
driver as well as these Max Fly 2023
Tour X golf balls but if you can't
decide you can always get Dad a Dick's
Sporting Goods gift card and that way he
can get exactly what he wants find more
inspiration for the dads in your life at
dicks.com
Heaven oh